We get support from UC Davis, a globally ranked university, working to solve the world's most pressing problems in food, energy, health, education, and the environment. UC Davis researchers collaborate and innovate in California and around the globe to find transformational solutions. It's all part of the university's mission to promote quality of life for all living things. Find out more at 21stCentry.ucdavis.edu Find out more at 21stCentry.ucdavis.edu. This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. If I asked you to close your eyes and mimic the action of using one of the simple human interfaces in everyday life, you could probably do it.
我们得到了加州大学戴维斯分校的支持，这是一所全球排名的大学，致力于解决世界在食品、能源、健康、教育和环境方面最紧迫的问题。加州大学戴维斯分校的研究人员在加州和全球范围内合作创新，寻找变革性的解决方案。这一切都是该大学促进所有生物生活质量使命的一部分。欲了解更多信息，请访问 21stCentry.ucdavis.edu。这是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马斯。如果我让你闭上眼睛，模仿日常生活中使用简单人机界面的动作，你可能做得到。
No problem. Without having a button to push, you could close your eyes and pretend to push a button. And that action would accurately reflect the action of pushing a real button, same with flipping a switch, or turning a door knob. If you close your eyes and fake the movement, it would sync up with its real world use. Now if I asked you to do the same thing with a car's steering wheel, you'd think you'd be able to describe steering accurately and mime the correct movements with your hands in the air.
没问题。即使没有按钮可按，你也可以闭上眼睛假装按下一个按钮。这个动作会准确地反映按下真实按钮的动作，翻转开关或转动门把手也是如此。如果你闭上眼睛模仿这些动作，它们会与现实世界中的使用同步。现在，如果我让你对汽车的方向盘做同样的事情，你可能会认为自己能够准确地描述转向动作，并用悬在空中的双手模仿出正确的动作。
But you'd be wrong, so wrong. You'd probably kill a bunch of imaginary people. But don't just take my word for it. Yeah, but I was Steve, I'm not even in fact a engineer. His full name is Dr. Steve Kloat. He just introduced himself as Steve. He's a casual guy. And what was your research on?
但你错了，大错特错。你可能会“杀死”一群虚构的人。但别只听我的一面之词。是的，我是史蒂夫，事实上我甚至不是工程师。他的全名是史蒂夫·克洛特博士。他只是简单地介绍了自己是史蒂夫。他是个随和的人。你的研究是关于什么的？
What's your main research you've done? And that's Tristan Cook and Thomas Nelson is also in the room there asking questions of Steve. Tristan and Tom run this awesome blog called Humans and Design. My interests are in drive-to behavior. So here's the exercise. Put your hands up and grip an imaginary steering wheel. Ten and two. No, I want you to mine the action of changing lanes to the right. So every try it. Alright, if you're like most people, and according to Steve's research, we're talking the vast majority of people. You turn your imaginary wheel 45 degrees to the right or so, and then back to the center.
你的主要研究是什么？那是特里斯坦·库克，托马斯·尼尔森也在房间里向史蒂夫提问。特里斯坦和汤姆经营着一个很棒的博客，叫《人类与设计》。我的兴趣在于驾驶行为。所以，我们来做个练习。举起双手，握住一个虚构的方向盘。十点和两点方向。不，我要你模仿向右变道的动作。大家试一下。好吧，如果你和大多数人一样，根据史蒂夫的研究，我们指的是绝大多数人，你会把虚构的方向盘向右转动45度左右，然后回到中心。
And that's the action for changing lanes. But that's not right. What you've described is actually a sequence of the movements that you require for turning the corner. To actually change lanes, you have to turn the steering wheel to the right, then turn it back crossing the center line, turning the wheel and equal amplitude to the left to correct your heading, and then back to the center. Knowing that this weird brain hiccup existed, Steve's team at the University of Queensland tested people in driving simulators, and sure enough, if you provided visual feedback, people could change lanes no problem.
这就是变道的动作。但那是不对的。你所描述的实际上是你转弯时所需的一系列动作。要真正变道，你必须向右转动方向盘，然后转回来穿过中心线，向左转动相同幅度的方向盘来修正航向，然后再回到中心。史蒂夫的团队在昆士兰大学测试了驾驶模拟器中的人们，发现这种奇怪的大脑“打嗝”确实存在。果然，如果你提供视觉反馈，人们变道就没问题。
But as soon as you turned off the screen or blindfolded them and told them to change lanes, even though they had only just moments ago successfully performed the correct action, they couldn't do it. Given no other feedback, you can't change lanes using a steering wheel without vision. I mean since cars are designed to be driven with your eyes open, that's okay. In fact, this is a funky example that doesn't mean that a steering wheel is a bad interface design. You could probably argue the opposite.
但一旦你关掉屏幕或蒙住他们的眼睛，让他们变道，即使他们几秒钟前才成功执行了正确的动作，他们也做不到了。在没有其他反馈的情况下，你无法在没有视觉的情况下使用方向盘变道。我的意思是，既然汽车设计成睁眼驾驶，那也没关系。事实上，这是一个有趣的例子，并不意味着方向盘的设计很糟糕。你甚至可以反驳说它设计得很好。
You could argue that a steering wheel is so well designed that anyone can use it with just a little bit of feedback in the real world even though they can't describe how they use it in the abstract. It's like people didn't learn, they just did the same. Those are the course of an experiment, which takes about 45 minutes to an hour. The size of the error was pretty consistent. But Steven and his researchers decided to test this in a real car. So Steve got some from like $50 million worth of insurance and took people out in a real car and drove them down a test road and then took their vision away and asked them to change
你可以说方向盘设计得非常好，以至于任何人在现实世界中只要有一点点反馈就能使用它，即使他们无法在抽象层面描述如何使用它。就像人们没有学习，只是自然而然地做了。这些是一个实验的过程，大约需要45分钟到一个小时。误差的大小相当一致。但史蒂夫和他的研究人员决定在真车上测试这一点。所以史蒂夫搞到了价值约5000万美元的保险，带人们开真车去测试道路上，然后剥夺他们的视觉，让他们变道。
lanes. Our friends Tristan and Tom were two of the participants. The first time you took vision away from me, it was absolutely terrifying. Yeah. It's a little bit like when Obi-Wan Kenobi was teaching Luke Skywalker how to use a light saber without using his eyes. With the blash you'll down I can't even see. In the first few runs people made the same mistake they did in the simulator. Essentially they were told to change lanes and they move the steering wheel in such a way that they turned a corner instead.
我们的朋友特里斯坦和汤姆是参与者中的两位。第一次你剥夺我的视觉时，那绝对是令人恐惧的。是的。这有点像欧比旺·克诺比教卢克·天行者如何在不使用眼睛的情况下使用光剑。蒙上眼睛我什么都看不见。在最初的几次尝试中，人们犯了和在模拟器中一样的错误。本质上，他们被告知要变道，但他们转动方向盘的方式却是转弯。
But here's where things get really interesting. Stretch out with your feelings. People gradually started to improve and by the end of the real world blind trial, they were performing almost perfect lane change. In my experience there's no such thing as luck. There's the vestibular system that senses your balance or the somato-sensory system that senses pressure on your skin as your thigh presses into the seat as you turn a corner. One gives an aneronia signal.
但有趣的地方来了。用你的感觉去延伸。人们逐渐开始进步，到现实世界盲测结束时，他们已经能执行近乎完美的变道了。以我的经验，运气是不存在的。有感知平衡的前庭系统，或者当你转弯时大腿压在座椅上感知压力的体感系统。一个信号会产生错误。
The others would correct it. Well, that's right. Using all those extra senses, people learned how to perform the lane change in a real car blindfolded. But here's the crazy part. After it was over over they asked the participants to mime a lane change with an imaginary steering wheel in their hands. And sure enough, they
其他的会纠正它。嗯，没错。利用所有这些额外的感官，人们学会了如何在蒙眼的情况下在真车中执行变道。但疯狂的部分在于，结束后，他们要求参与者用手模仿虚构方向盘上的变道动作。果然，他们
went right back to making the same mistake performing a corner turn instead of a lane change. This is a reward and how it was resistant to learning. The steering wheel is pretty nicely mapped to our intuition, but it still requires the slightest bit of feedback so that our brain knows how to use it, but we still manage. Also, I can't stress this enough, people. Don't dry-ply unfold it. Really, you're just not going to be able to do it. Alright, I'm glad we got this job. 99% Indusible was produced by Tristan Cook and Thomas Nelson of the blog Humans In Design,
又回到了犯同样的错误，执行了转弯而不是变道。这是一种奖励，以及它是如何抵制学习的。方向盘很好地映射了我们的直觉，但它仍然需要一点点反馈，以便我们的大脑知道如何使用它，但我们还是做到了。另外，我怎么强调都不为过，大家，千万别蒙眼开车。真的，你根本做不到。好吧，我很高兴我们完成了这项工作。《99%隐形》由《人类与设计》博客的特里斯坦·库克和托马斯·尼尔森制作，
fun at war at humansanddesign.com and me Roman Mars. It's made possible with support from Lunar, making a difference with creativity. It's a project of KALW, 91.7 local public radio in San Francisco, the American Institute of Architects in San Francisco, and the Center for Architecture and Design. To find out more, go to the website at 99%invisible.org. This fire is burning still, put it out when we lose the thrill. I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, I'm drunk, Here's an interesting sign note. If you want people to pretend to perform a perfect lane change blindfolded, here's what you tell them. You say, dodge an obstacle in the road and then return back to your current lane.
网址是 humansanddesign.com，还有我罗曼·马斯。它的制作离不开 Lunar 的支持，他们用创造力创造了不同。这是旧金山当地公共广播电台 KALW 91.7、旧金山美国建筑师协会以及建筑与设计中心的一个项目。欲了解更多信息，请访问网站 99%invisible.org。这火还在烧，当我们失去激情时就把它扑灭。我喝醉了……（重复多次）。这里有一个有趣的附注。如果你想让人在蒙眼的情况下假装执行完美的变道，你应该这样告诉他们。你说，躲避路上的障碍物，然后回到你当前的行车道。
That movement, perfect lane change. and then return back to your current lane. That movement, perfectly in change. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
那个动作，完美的变道。然后回到你当前的行车道。那个动作，完美的变道。这一集还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。